hallo herzlich willkommen zu salehs welt
heute gibt es wieder ein video zum thema
cache basics ich mache heute eine
leckere deutsche buttercreme die heißt
deswegen deutsche buttercreme weil sie
aus pudding und aus butter besteht und
die kann man dann benutzen um zum
beispiel torten zu befüllen oder eben um
auch cafés zu bespritzen und ich mache
jetzt erst mal die ganz klassische
variante mit milch und vanille und
später mache ich auch noch eine
fruchtige variante aber ich zeige jetzt
erstmal die zutaten
ich brauche dafür 660 milliliter milch
135 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
oder ihr nehmt eine vanilleschote hier
habe ich eine prise salz 60 gramm
speisestärke für eigelbe das sind auch
60 gramm und 420 gramm weiche butter die
brauche ich aber erst später und ich
benutze diese menge jetzt gleich um
später eine 26er form also 26 hatte
damit zu gefühlt und deswegen reicht
diese menge aber wir können euch die mir
ja auch gerne hoch oder runter rechnen
und zuerst wird jetzt aus den ersten
zutaten also außer der mutter eine creme
hergestellt auf dem pudding und dafür
gebe ich jetzt zuerst mal die milch in
einem topf
das nehme jetzt erst mal nur einen teil
denn ich mich da gleich die eigelbe mit
rein rühren und die schön glatt rühren
dann kommt da auch die speisestärke mit
rein
und auch direkt der zucker dann noch die
prise salz
und jetzt noch reichlich vanille je
nachdem wie intensiv wir den geschmack
haben wollte
und jetzt will ich hier noch die
restliche milch mit heil- und lass es
dann bei mittlerer hitze etwas aufkochen
das dauert es ein paar minuten aber auf
jeden fall bei mittlerer hitze machen
damit sich das langsam erwärmen kann man
kann das alte darin auch nicht gewinnen
und hat später gleichen super pudding
und wenn der pudding dann aufgekocht ist
völlig in damit er einfach schneller
abkühlt da ist jetzt auch richtig schön
fest und muss jetzt erstmal abkühlen und
damit sich da jetzt kein haut darüber
bildet muss ich den direkt mit
frischhaltefolie abdecken direkt über
der haut und dann lasse ich ihn einfach
in der küche stehen und auf
zimmertemperatur und die butter hat ja
auch zimmertemperatur
das heißt wenn der pudding dann
zimmertemperatur hat kann ich ihn später
mit der mutter verbinden
aber in der zwischenzeit zeige ich euch
jetzt noch mal die fruchtige variante
für die fruchtige variante habt ihr
jetzt die gleichen zutaten nur nehmen
die jetzt etwas fruchtsaft um eben die
frucht buttercreme herzustellen und ich
nehme jetzt etwas fruchtsaft und auch
etwas bruch zugleich und zwar jetzt vier
mango saft und mango fleisch und macht
das jetzt so dass es erst dieses manko
fleisch herausnehmen und das pürieren
und dann mit dem saft auffüllen
ihr könnt da übrigens auch ganz andere
früchte nehmen wie zum beispiel
himbeeren erdbeeren heidelbeeren
brombeeren was er gerne möchte und so
das ganze eben mit etwas saft aufhören
jetzt trenne ich hier mal dieses hoch
fleisch raus
und jetzt wird das grob gewürfelt
und jetzt will ich das fruchtfleisch
noch mit etwas saft aus und püriertes
schön glatt und da nimmt er jetzt so
viel dass eben auf die bestimmte menge
kommt also ich brauche jetzt in meinem
fall 500 gramm
weil ich jetzt eine kleinere menge an
buttercreme machen kann auch sein dass
etwas mehr benötigt und dann müsst ihr
euch das einfach so abfüllen
und jetzt geht es genauso weiter wie mit
der milch auch hier brauchte ja
eventuell jetzt etwas weniger zucker ihr
müsst einfach mal ab schmecken wie süß
die früchte schon sind ob der saft
gesüßt war deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier
nur ein bisschen zucker
denn die mango und der sanfte war nicht
schon süß genug
das wird jetzt kurz verrührt und daraus
koche ich jetzt aus diesen drei zutaten
+ salz auch in pudding
der pudding ist abgekühlt und jetzt muss
ich ihnen einmal durch ein sieb
streichen damit einfach keine klümpchen
mehr vorhanden sind und das mache ich
jetzt hier in so einem feinen hasi und
in der zeit während ich das hier durch
streicher kann ich auch schon mal die
zimmerer mutter einfach schön verrühren
damit sie weiß cremig wird
und jetzt gebe es erste hinweise den
pudding zur weichen butter mit dazu
so sehen jetzt meine fertigen butter
cremes aus komischerweise sehen jetzt
beide fast identisch aus denn beide sind
ja auf eine helle basis aufgebaut
ich habe ich einmal die mango creme und
einmal die vanille buttercreme und diese
könnte jetzt als torten füllung benutzen
ihr könnt sie allerdings nicht als
untergrund für condor benutzen weil die
deutsche buttercreme einfach dafür viel
zu feucht ist und es würde denn von dort
auf reichen
das heißt dieser jetzt nur als füllung
benutzen und wenn ihr motiv torte damit
befüllen wollt müsst ihr trotzdem
außenrum etwas ganz streichen
das werde ich jetzt gleich machen und
ihr dürft diese rezepte gerne nachlesen
auf salehs - blog.de und ich freue mich
aufs nächste mal bis dann